Hey everyone. My name is Nishant Gupta
and I'm a software engineering tech lead
at Meta
working on building the training and
inference infrastructure
for the Meta Super Dangerous Lab and the
infrastructure organization.
Today we're going to be talking about
production of ads for agentic systems.
When most people hear the word
evaluation, they think about benchmarks.
A model scores 90% on a benchmark. A new
version scores 92%. The team celebrates.
But agentic systems have fundamentally
changed what the evaluation means.
Today the systems don't simply generate
answers. They plan. They call tools.
They retrieve information. They execute
workflows. They interact with the
production infrastructure.
The question is no longer did the model
generate the right answer?
The question is did the system behave
correctly?
Today I would like to discuss how
evaluation is evolving from model
benchmarking into production
infrastructure.
This is the problem almost every AI
organization is encountering today.
Offline benchmarks continue improving.
Yet production reliability often remains
unpredictable.
Why is that?
Because benchmarks measure model
capability. Production measures system
behavior. A benchmark doesn't capture
tool failure, API outage, context
changes, user variability, long running
workflows.
And as systems become more autonomous,
the gap between the benchmark
performance and production performance
grows.
The result is what many teams experience
today.
High benchmark scores, as you can see,
but unreliable production behavior.
Traditional LLM evaluation focus on
outputs.
But we should ask the question did the
model produce the correct answer?
Agentic systems force us to ask a
different question. Did the system
behave correctly? Behavior includes
planning quality, tool usage, execution,
workflow execution, recovery from
failures, decision-making. In other
words, we are moving from evaluating
answers to evaluating workflows. And
that requires fundamentally different
evaluation architectures.
Many teams still think hallucinations
are the primary AI failure modes. In
production, they are often just one
category.
Agentic systems introduce an entire
hierarchy of failure modes. At the very
foundation, the memory failures,
retrieval failures, safety failures. As
you go up, you have to think about
reasoning mistakes, poor planning,
incorrect tool execution. At the highest
layer, you have to think about
multi-agent coordination failures.
And this is why evaluating only model
output misses the most production risk
we observe.
One of the most useful mindset shifts is
to stop thinking like researchers and
start thinking like a SRE or a
production engineer.
SREs don't measure success using
accuracy. They measure reliability,
availability, latency, cost, recovery.
And agentic systems require the same
approach.
The goal is not maximizing the benchmark
scores. The goal is to maximize
dependable outcomes.
Reliability becomes the North Star
metric.
Accuracy becomes the only input.
In this pyramid is how I think
personally think about modern AI
evaluation systems. At the bottom, you
can see they are benchmarks. They are
useful. They are scalable. They are
repeatable. But their operational value
is limited.
In the middle, there are scenario-based
evaluations. These simulate realistic
workflows.
And at the very top, you see production
telemetry. This is where the highest
value evaluation signals come from. The
surprising insight is that the most
evaluation data often comes from real
users interacting with real systems.
Now, let's talk about AI offline
evaluations. So, offline evaluation
still matters, but the methodology
changes. Instead of evaluating prompts,
we evaluate scenarios. For example,
a customer support workflow, a code
generation workflow, a research
workflow. The agent operates inside that
simulated environment. We measure the
task completion rate, tool correctness,
planning quality, resource usage, which
is which becomes
exponentially high at high scale.
The key takeaway, agent evaluation
should be scenario driven, not prompt
driven.
Once a system reaches production, every
interaction becomes a signal.
This is one of the biggest shifts in
evaluation thinking. Production traffic
is no longer just traffic. It becomes
evaluation data.
We collect execution traces,
user outcomes, escalations, failures,
feedback signals. Production is the
largest and the most representative
evaluation data any organization will
ever have.
Many organizations view humans as
fallback systems. I think that's a wrong
framing. Humans are the evaluators. They
provide signals that automated systems
cannot. They assess correctness, trust,
usefulness, safety. These signals become
really critical for calibrating
evaluation pipelines and identifying
blind spots in automated metrics.
The most successful systems combine
automated evaluation with targeted human
review.
Now, agent systems drift constantly.
Model changes. You have a new version
every couple of weeks or months. Prompts
can change, tools can change, user
behavior can change. The challenge is
that no longer single change appear
catastrophic. Reliability slowly
degrades. Success rate declines,
escalation increases, tool failure
rises. Without continuous evaluation,
teams often don't discover drift until
users complain.
Continuous monitoring becomes essential.
Observability and evaluation are
inseparable inseparable. To evaluate an
agent, we need visibility into the
reasoning paths, the tool calls, the
memory access, execution timelines, the
state transitions, as you can see here
in this chart,
traditional logs are not sufficient. We
need detailed traces, just like with any
deep nested microservice architecture
for any application or service you're
talking about.
Agent traces become the equivalent of
distributed tracing for autonomous
workloads. Without observability,
evaluation becomes the guesswork.
Let's talk about the continuous
evaluation loop because evaluation is an
always-running service, not a testing
phase.
Historically, evaluation always happened
before deployment, but now evaluation
continues after deployment till you may
identify issues, as you can see in A.
Human reviews the edge cases, feedback
improves the data sets, offline
scenarios validate updates, the loop
never stops.
Evaluation is no longer just a phase,
it's an operational capability.
This is probably the most important
slide in this presentation. Every metric
shown here maps directly to a business
outcome.
Task completion measures value
delivered. Tool success measures
operational reliability.
Escalation rate measures human burden.
Safety violations measure risk exposure.
Latency affects user experience. Cost
determines scalability. Recovery rate
reflects resilience.
And notice but notice that accuracy is
missing.
It's not because accuracy doesn't
matter, but because business success
depends on much more than just accuracy.
Now, this is the architecture where the
industry is heading more or less.
Evaluation becomes part of the control
plane, not a separate tool, not an
offline process. The control plane
continuously, which observes the
systems, collects telemetry, runs
simulations, coordinates human review,
and the execution plane performs the
work. The control plane measures and
governs the behavior, and this
separation is becoming a foundational
pattern for production AI systems.
Now, let's summarize the key lessons.
First, benchmarks remains necessary, but
they are insufficient.
Second, agent systems must be valued as
workflows, not individual outputs.
Third, production telemetry is a most
important evaluation signal.
Fourth, reliability ultimately matters
more than raw model accuracy. And
finally, evaluation is becoming
the infrastructure, not testing, not QA
infrastructure.
This is the shift every organization
building agent AI will eventually need
to make.